thank you Gary how are you great
pleasure to meet you nice to meet you
man have an operation here very
impressive
thank you brother turtle several more
floors that are even more interesting
that's awesome that's awesome I'm not
going to do we got here because of my
dad
yes the only guy that can penetrate my
schedule so I sold my business in August
yep
for money a decent a good amount
congratulations and thank you and and
you're a young guy I'm a young guy so on
how old are you 43 young so I built this
business from I'm a second-generation
like you were but I came in similar to
you small and blue in about three
million in sales
yep when we sold it we did it just under
30 million before you man so for 20 like
literally 20 years 20 years 20 to 40 to
89 came in 1994 so and I get a little
bit of them jumping around a little bit
but in 2007-2008 the economy's tanking
and unfortunately or fortunately
depending on how you look at it I ended
up getting to doing this sorry timing I
was actually good because the men's mess
was how you'd last was a pretty
miserable time I'm sorry kids in my life
you know that I still had and it was
just brutal time where did you lift a
little Randolph now and I was actually
in Randolph had to cut it so I went
through this kind of awakening yep and I
started to study I hadn't read a book in
20 years yeah I probably read 30 books
all self-improvement
yes and he wants as though he wanted to
get into a happier place I want to
figure out how do I train myself and I
just grabbed onto it
okay and it was amazing to the point
where it changed everything change my
change of business to change your life
the people you hung out with I don't I
get it I know when from being broke yep
I mean to live in a beautiful home with
a new wife
get my kids drive a Ferrari ultimate
supreme in
and I really got into this personal
development and I have actually done
some speaking not professionally it's a
whole different I've gone but I've done
I spoke to the entire so I mean it's a
punch line of this knowing we have
limited time yeah you want to explore
building up your brand and talk about
how you did it yes okay yeah and I also
have you know I'm also doing a bunch of
other things right now I'm actually
going to be investing in a Lexus
dealership which is something I don't
know how much investing you do and
outside is is I do a ton but but I focus
my time and attention to early stage you
know I was an investor and Tumblr and
Twitter I'm going for Grand Slam
scotches like by the way I love the
practical like one of my buddies has me
all hot on buying like pizza places that
in New York that are buck a slight like
in two years you're making money I'm I
feel like the practical thing I do is
building businesses you know what I mean
if I sold my business and was like if I
was done meaning like done operating I
would invest in dealerships and realist
like more practical stuff which makes
sense I because I'm operating this is
practical and I'm going for by the
[ __ ] jet so that's another reason why
I'm here again I did well but instead of
millions I'm focused now on hundreds of
millions for Billy you're always felt
that I've had a destiny to do something
greater but not necessary to be famous I
get it but to do something more
substantial and and then so give so
given that I have to do a public speech
yeah and I've got certain things I've
got to do and we have very limited time
and I don't know I'm loving the vibe
here
I love anybody who says I things about
my dad is going to win this makes a ton
of sense I understand why you wanted to
get 10 minutes with me what's the main
question what should you do next I think
the main I think really I came to try to
just get some energy from you got it I
don't here's the real energy ready I
think you need to put out cut if you
want to do hundreds of millions and you
want to build you and you're willing to
be out there which is all the clear
indications you are you have to put out
content whether through written video or
audio or all or
one buck man if you can do all you do it
uh you've got to do it and I didn't you
knows how I did it now I have now I have
a documentary every day going on like
like you've got to put out content every
day so my question to that is as I
studied and yep I'm sure you've seen a
lot of the content it's the same content
but done in a different way or a
different spin yep
you know all the personal development
stuff that would you read Tony raffia
Jim Rhon yep the same stuff but done
differently of course so is that yeah it
is take look I'll give you a better
piece of advice than that I would do you
yeah like Ivan said the other day in
dailyvee I don't want to be a
motivational speaker I'm motivating that
I'm high-energy but I don't I'd never
read a line or listen to a word of Jim
Rohn okay for Napoleon Hill right and
I'm friendly with Tony Robbins because I
like him I've been event I've never
listened to a CD or what read a book I
don't know anything about any of these
people just better I mean triple zero I
don't know I know I get us donors like
know who they are is because I get
associated with them right but I
continue at all costs to not consume any
of it because then it's not me correct
what I am is motivational but I'm
building the 600 [ __ ] people working
here I'm like [ __ ] up Madison Avenue
because I'm revolutionising the
advertising world in agency form the way
I did for liquor stores I think we need
those guys to build wine library I did
me now it sounds like you consumed so
that was just fine my biggest piece of
advice is to unwind that and be you
abundance should talk about why you were
broken divorce and not happy and what
listen you're a byproduct you're a
byproduct of that stuff motivating
something quick and I don't know if you
know what that is a listen I've been
putting out content of ten years trying
to understand myself I really and say
that but I think you just have to go
honest as [ __ ] and I will tell you the
number one thing that scares the [ __ ]
animation nice watches and Ferraris
here's what I need to just do not sell
these people [ __ ] very real it's got
to be valuable because we'll make money
bring your grandkids are going to think
you are dick right understood it's not
an actual [ __ ] business
you're not a [ __ ] self-help coach
that only sells info products right do
you have a skill set you're right I have
you [ __ ] did something now you need a
motivation to get up in the morning and
work hard enough and smart enough and
have the energy to drive that business
but you know how to [ __ ] instantly
you will craft that and then how do you
motivate people staying here or of
course I just went on and what about
selling like how do you pitch projects
like a little bit it's going to be very
if you leave its garyvee just by saying
[ __ ] I'll send up a flare anyone
asking is one of the ways right like I'm
surprised it happens like you know like
look look look look it comes down to
very simple things which is do not get
caught up in taking a [ __ ] pretty
picture like on a vacation on a [ __ ]
boat on Instagram and selling these
people [ __ ] yeah everybody's doing
that is everywhere you go you built a
business that's what you pound on okay
and if you happen to be motivating and
charismatic all about all the [ __ ]
banners but there's plenty of people
that none of these people have ever
heard of making Bank and they're not
charismatic and they're not clever and
or not cute or interesting they're just
[ __ ] making hundreds of billions of
dollars running businesses ninety-eight
percent of your energy and how you built
your business and how it transformed
like was it that you were unhappy like
truth did you get divorce because cool
of [ __ ] knows but the further you're
willing to go down the truth barrel the
more you're going to win and personal
yeah I mean you start you're telling
your story right I think you would write
right up ten pieces but then talk about
all sorts of [ __ ] tell my tell them half
and I mean literally how I have ten
minutes with Gary Vaynerchuk it's
actually it's a great story I came into
a meeting cynical then I met the guy I
always remember his name funny name
visited another like that's a story how
about how about the first deal you got
after being upset how about the first
feelings out of 22 so listen I think all
I can tell you is if you get anything
out of me is all the hyperbole in the
[ __ ] and drama and
excitement and energy and accolades that
I have the thing I feel best about you
know my dad - better than you know me is
there's truth behind it I love that
because I know a lot of people that
there are isn't ya and don't be one of
those people it's too easy
you've made a big step there's my man
sir let me know man like those are those
are hundreds of thousands and millions
for the couple people that are the best
at being [ __ ]
you already made that but the [ __ ] are
you playing hundreds of thousands of
millions you want something real what's
with the [ __ ] real play for tens and
hundreds that only comes in real [ __ ]
don't sell [ __ ] [ __ ] that's not true
no [ __ ] secret the secret isn't real
like I hope that's not real it's [ __ ]
work it's like you know how you build
the business in 20 years especially work
your face off like you woke up at 6 I
went to the job and it snowed but you've
got to show up because if that person
said you were a dick then this
organization was going to use you talk
about accountability talk about when
there's only three or four major
builders in New Jersey that you can't
[ __ ] up ever because once your
reputation [ __ ] you're out there's a
million people that want a [ __ ]
insulate yeah got it yeah
the man man I don't initiate it take
care of much okay well I wish you out
very much my pleasure no you're good
take care of yourself
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]